una pregunta está viva la alta costura
hoy en día obviamente estamos aquí no
está muerta hoy es muy emocionante
llevar algo que se ha hecho sobre tu
cuerpo te hace única esto es muy
emocionante me encanta estar aquí es
mucho trabajo realmente es un arte así
que me siento muy honrada de estar aquí
en el desfile de dior y en París sin
hijos ni marido es muy agradable
[Música]
la alta costura nunca ha estado mejor
que ahora después de louisvito dio es el
otro buque insignia del líder mundial
del lujo
lbmh cuyo beneficio Neto en 2022 superó
los 14 mil millones de euros la alta
costura es una potencia económica
una potencia artística
Ah bueno eso seguro Ah bueno Sí sí un
diseñador de moda es un es un artista En
todo caso Sí eso seguro es una profesión
sociológica es un trabajo en el que
captas influencias en el que captas en
el que das una imagen de la mujer en el
que otorgas una imagen de las relaciones
hombre mujer es todo muy muy sutil y
requiere sensibilidad inteligencia Y
análisis
para esta colección de la alta costura
verano 2023 María Gracias churi director
artística de diog decidió rendir
homenaje a la elegante modernidad de las
artistas negras del París ya los años 20
y más concretamente a Josephine Baker
fue muy importante para la cultura
francesa y creo que era bueno celebrarlo
porque ella estaba implicada al igual
que Catherine Dion
no tu forgot no hay que olvidar que era
una clienta real y que acudía a las
casas de moda parisinas para comprar su
vestuario
y cuando regresa a Nueva York se lleva
consigo esta increíble vestuario de alta
costura en cierto modo promovió la alta
costura francesa en Estados Unidos por
eso es muy importante rendirle homenaje
fue una época muy importante para la
moda cambiaron las siluetas se abandonó
el corsé fue un momento revolucionario
no hay que olvidar que el París de los
años 20 era el centro de la creatividad
artistas de todo el mundo acuden a París
donde expresar libremente su visión
artística del mundo
es una época muy importante para la moda
me encanta
mi última colaboración con dior una de
mis favoritas fue en la gala del Met de
Nueva York cuando María gracia homenajeó
a Joseph Baker Así que asistir a este
desfile de moda es comprender todas las
influencias pasando por las primeras top
models era una magnífica colección que
rendía homenaje a este patrimonio
es un mensaje social o incluso político
absolutamente porque es un mensaje
intemporal es el legado de gente como
James Baldwin no son solo artistas que
amaron profundamente a Francia y la
libertad que esta supo darles también
son columnistas que se han jugado la
vida para defender lo que es justo
Estas son las personas que admiramos
estas son las personas que nos guían hoy
y ahora lejos de las pasarelas
recalentadas aquí una alta costura sin
ánimo de lucro oliviese Jack historiador
antiguo conservador de museos de moda
actualmente director de la fundación
asesin alaia y también director
artístico de la empresa de calzado
Weston escribe y desarrolla las
performances moda y arte su quinta obra
del ciclo moda povera se titula la ropa
de René René es mi madre cuando
desapareció fue por la época del covid
pero 9 sino que acabábamos de pasar
varios meses con ella tenía una edad muy
avanzada
mis hermanos y yo hemos estado lidiando
con esta situación que se tiene cuando
se trata de la ropa de una persona
desaparecida pero aún así pensé fui
conservador de un museo de moda director
y se inventarios de todos los vestidos
del mundo desde el décimo octavo hasta
nuestros días Es imposible que no le
haga nada a la ropa de mi madre Así que
la metí toda en cajas Pero todas de
verdad luego esperé y un día tuve la
idea ya que habíamos empezado Esta obra
moda povera dije pero es con ella con
quien debemos hacerlo y con este
proyecto Se acabaron las ambigüedades en
moda hacemos moda como si escribiéramos
poesía pero no tenemos nada que vender y
estoy contento con ella
es un homenaje a la belleza de lo que se
puede hacer con cualquier cosa solo
pequeñas cosas para transformaciones
es decir algo que realmente ha
vivido de una determinada manera y darle
otra vida otra dignidad
y la elevó la ropa era sencilla era
normal y él es de una majestuosidad una
costura absolutamente excepcional
Eso es Es Muy conmovedor realmente es
que todo el mundo estaba muy enganchado
porque sentías que estaba pasando algo
todas las prendas de René han sido
transformadas con técnicas de alta
costura sus pañuelos se han convertido
en delicados guantes pedagogía poética
René era taxista
[Aplausos]